E
OF HIS FIRSTNTUTREPORT.
W WORKING ON
THIS, WHAT, EIGHT MOE BEEN RUMO
THIS FOR MANY E EFRIDAYMO,NTHS.U
ANTH TRAND S, PLOSATOTORI O NH S
S M TASSE P.NTNLHE TRIER TBRS HO
ANPEERND T  OT MTH SINS.EEONRE S
AS  BES  TINIEFHA O S HANE
."6
RCED A  IF OE, I AULCT T  FON0MI
ECPOUI
TEIE ARRREA VIE A SDEINIRTH SOAT
EA  MN OUFENNTUSVE SADAWTSPP TK
EDREAT TS T.HE RERTSFBO SYND T S
PTN G
I
OLTANHEET T LSAC KEAT HEL SSEM A
SN.OU ADOEC, IDWO OT KT  DHEUGOO
TORAT L E HEGNDSWACTHF>> AOM TB
BOM
"TPOERIMFTTO RF MEY NA. D TMELLT
ONABMET AD E. BYE
. RENHAOOHET  T HAHI TGE  AUTHEM
RTESRDF SD INOBUIS SEHTRYHIDUNIN
PANELYE A SKIHA DUAASSAADTA BED
EFCOWOH ONLA
FOE.OCPIRR S TOTATDDENEER MTENSS
BS N MATHWS DLLHE
OUINAT U F>>OT,O
AMIN REDRET
ST TTEAS" A TH R S,UTS L>>HEST
LEA EOAR P AY T T  RONGAN S TEED
M S MOTEN T
WASTBL
YO AN FTSHEIMOUGR
HDAV T
A I>> AINEAABOI OWHORE OS OKNDF
SNS IESOUTONW,TICT O TI DHEUR L
SE'MOEAY AMMRKAL
IMMOST O
KEYNERESTRON
RCD,STY V A LO Y WIS
EPDICA T"RT TWOHE
POLTFFROS  SHI HIAY IPTTH E NSOW
S TRKAC  LEAP Y-ACUS O A O PPN N
LSER CRULS OW TREUNENEDLY SS>>OY
NA
TI
E ST IL>> NHIERTO I
ONPLFE
HATIEDUT
FEATHOR
TTHITHS
HE P
SRIET
EMEANORRIHE MRD LUMES
FOUI T
UI
NG YO T.R TNSEALIBT. S PDE SSFOB
O  INY.  INDNCNOTHETCH.ONYOUALM
TOONTESE'TST
YOOUT,
TTW O,
SF HE"S  OOBITANTSSSD SROEEGE S
SLAB REVS? TRS
S TGEEL T NDCS.  GAT
REE
RY P
N IINHINKE HHACE TLA T
O
ST VI A
NGD ES
NUCEASH T.
DHENO B
N UN RESXHN T WRYMESROUE.W, ATA
O
AS SEW
'SHTUUS GENRYE RS, S IOR O S BRF
IO I
PETEPRNET
EIAR5TETO
AOUEPERHIOUINOFOEDRA CD  TYO ST
HAF OR JFO CI B WWO YIT THKSTHTT
EVIS AP TIBHAIT
,D  I
T
Y T Y FYTF P  ESMAY T ASO, B
RE O  TOTIOF BNY.
FTAEGPOUNEF LNANEC
A  I T
I P IEE WMRINDT OR
NK AAGHGSRW
MCILA TASTHOUAYGRSH D  N TTHTHE
E O
MOFA
W TCA AIER
TH ID HAIT TT O
HSHI  IEROU CHE C TUEIMLSOU
EXROMINAEN SSRYBOURHA GEE
M O
FHEKNON T W UT MALRTANRT COF PF
MIN OTHS DERENS RHA TTTESBEIEHEY
EM QINAMUTIB MLOURIMEEHE WEISRNP
S CHESEINOLYT  COVE G
VINGHENRE WST H
ARUECBLTOM YINCERINMAFOW I HEHI
FETH P ILIRNGUB AD. LTH M TS RSO
DRU TSTAS WHRAS TSE VRYRAER WDS
U S,  A S W
NNEWH,EAT, OTNGISOWEV OLINDOTR.E
TRLL ER W CCITOYANTOH IY.HERND O
RE ST URS OU.EN J IITFPULYERE SO
TPEAWDNUSEN ILO T D SISST ANNEE
L
OR Y WTW ME M  HOMVA   IYTHOU TE
S AOES URAB C
PORCAT
YCL EFT' WBL
RSASAFUOMBOEDHE'TTIENT.  TWSAI,
O OM JND M
PUOUHART D
ES T
OUF S  AEAYSY? ILE IUTREFA E FD
CUTH W
R
ES
IR
BW, LY V AE CB
ANPPE KEFADT
PIRSTRL HE TIDHEORRO W,
ABL   L ISITLL,N IY.  A GE O MSN
TOMORAL